vos parents qu'est ce qui représente
pour vous aujourd'hui rien rien n'existe
plus n'existe pas vos deux frères aussi
comment pour vos deux frères séparés les
trois frères c'est vrai mais bon pour
vos autres frères au ccg fermeture du
rideau c'est fini fermeture du rythme
est ce que vous vous rappelez du
cauchemar qui a commencé alors que vous
aviez 8 9 mois se rappelait pas mais ces
voix là il paraît que ça a commencé
quand vous aviez 8 9 mois c'est ça c'est
des attestations de l'expert qui ont été
faites pendant l'instruction qui ont
attesté quand vu des lésions que j'avais
ça se référer à quelques mois alors sont
d'abord des violences de la maltraitance
des coûts ça c'est avait été hospitalisé
plus d'une dizaine de fois dès la
première année de votre vie c'est ça
c'est terrible
j'ai vécu avec vos parents et vos trois
frères jusqu'à vos six ans c'est ça et
ses six ans de maltraitances des abus
sexuels mais six ans de calvaire
c'est ça commence a commencé ces abus
sexuels et c1
c'est un jeu que mon père a lancé alors
d'une visite d'un couple de voisins ce
que vous pouvez parler bien fort je sais
pas si je me sens très ému je suis
désolé je suis à lille on est on est
bien
c'est un servile ou et c'est ça c'est un
jeu que mon père a lancé pendant une
visite du couple de voisins
c'est un
il voulait lancer un jeu sexuel entre 4
et cependant la tendance couple c'est ça
donc nous on était à côté dans le salon
et on a commencé à entendre du bruit et
on est rentré dans le salon voilà et là
vous avez eu en fait donc un de mes
frères qui a dit mais qu'est ce que
qu'est ce que vous faites et mon père
s'est levée et l'a dit ben tu vas savoir
donc là ça commence comme ça c'est ça a
commencé comme ça et après c'est ça
l'engrenage donc commencé ces manifs et
du ce comment ça s'est manifestée dans
cet engrenage
il ya des choses judiciairement parlant
cyril si je dit que vous pouvez vraiment
au chantier voila preniez de risque des
choses que je ne peux pas dire mais
c'est compliqué c'est parce que il ya
certaines choses que je peux pas dire
mais que je conte que vous pourrez avoir
l'occasion de le lire dans ce livre
parce que j'ai j'ai l'autorisation de le
faire bien sûr mais c'est un alors marc
vous dites que des tout-petits votre
père vous menacez pour que vous ne
parliez pas c'est ce qui se passait à la
maison c'est un as et même de mort oui
oui vous disais quoi
enfin il jouait sur la pression
psychologique on ne pourrait plus
rentrer à la maison qu'on pourrait pu
revoir papa et maman est dans la tête
d'un enfant 4 5 ans le fait est de pu
voir papa et maman quand on n'a pas
conscience de ce qui nous arrive c'est
très très compliqué paraît que vous
vivez des choses incroyables même avec
des débits sévices incroyable oui oui
vous raconter dans le livre c'est ça
avec des fourchettes notamment oui si
vous souhaitez passer en fait tout était
tout était organisé je ne sais pas
comment elle expliqué est votre meilleur
et votre père était étaient sur la même
longueur d'onde le tue ça y est votre
mère elle lui disait pas parfois je la
défendrai je la défendrai pas à ce qu'on
a toujours l'occasion de partir à un
moment donné elle n'était pas attaché à
un radiateur rien du tout enfin on se
doit on est en capacité de défendre ses
enfants et quoi qu'il arrive donc oui
forcément c'était vraiment le couple
barbares n'a pas de limites
abject alors en 2000 à 6 ans votre maire
demande aux services sociaux de ses
enfants
donc soit placé en famille d'accueil
c'est çà et là c'est un mythe heureux de
comment vous êtes limite euros de partir
de cet enfer pas tant que ça à tant que
ça pas tant que ça parce que il faut
remettre les choses dans le bon contexte
quand on a
cinq ans et demi être capable de faire
la différence entre ce qui est bien et
ce qui est mal c'est très compliqué faut
vraiment se mettre ça dans la tête et on
comprenait pas en fait c'est un tout à
rien et on comprend rien à ce qui se
passe c'est une après-midi banal mon
père demande à mes frères d'aller lui
chercher de la bière ma mère à ce moment
là s'il s'y refuse et dessin avec lui
pour l'empêcher de remonter et là une
valse endiablée d'affaires par la
fenêtre en furie je suis resté j'étais
j'ai encore cette image en tête j'étais
dans le canapé avec ma game boy dans les
mains il me l'a arraché des mains et la
plier en deux comme ça et lâcheté par la
fenêtre et ensuite il m'a il m'a passé
au dessus du ce
bakou
du cinquième étage
menaçant de me jeter si c'est c'est ma
mère ne remontait pas